for me just to become a director I think
the only way that I that I can imagine
to describe this strange profession in
my case is a kind of anthology of
ethology of frustration I mean I'm
afraid actor I am a frustrated musician
I'm a frustrated architecture I'm a
frustrated writer I'm a frustrated sex
symbol but I mean just to fill a big
interest in all these different
disciplines and that helps you to be a
director because just to direct a movie
participate of being architecture singer
actor writer and all that so in this
case is good it's good to be a
first-rate artist in all these fields
you know the origin of the ideas is
always very mysterious difficult to
explain but at the same time very for me
we're a hit I mean as material like this
table I mean for some of the last movie
I'm so excited I start I mean the first
sequence that I am that I wrote it was I
I try to just to to explain the
situation when someone that used to lie
a lot in one desperate situation that he
he said absolutely the truth the people
he called doesn't believe him so I mean
the situation was that I mean this
person was in a plane with a big problem
and hit why I mean he called someone I
mean one of the I mean his lover yes not
to explain in this ugly the situation
what he's trying to say goodbye or to
say something and and in that in that
moment I mean of course I mean they the
the girl doesn't believe him and in that
moment I was seized Isis in the top of a
bridge and no error how to say this
several Raul Salinas Balotelli for no
have phone slides it's time in this time
went a Madrid rich and of Viaduct of
Segovia it's called M II in telephone
okay phone falls AHA pasa el mejor de
steal or SQL committee una chica en
bicicleta below in the best manner of a
screwball ecology a girl passes by on a
bicycle elephant okay and then throw the
level sake gala in LA and the phone
falls inside the basket she has on the
bicycle you know call him picks it up in
peace hablar starts talking que ya es
una de tanto Samantha's Castillo
marathon you know and she turns out that
she is one of the many lovers that this
man has had it don't miss him whatever
this creature I am sorry I'm through
sequence yes so when those three sweet
quinces are written then those little
critters and then I want to find out
more about those two women characters II
gotta stay on me and more about that
male character about in IV on why is he
on the plane okay yes is Shawn Shawn why
are they the way they are Africa minion
and my own curiosity in front of the
development of that situation
Mia a escribir Eskimo if cooperative
para ver lo que una novella yo tengo que
es que VA NOLA it's almost like to find
out what's happening in a novel I have
to go on writing it it propels me
forward know someone ahem proper the
other day muchos mass
pero it's not a good example I could
give you many more but we don't have
much time I think it's a very good
example I try and I asked for some
rights to make a movie in English
unfortunately unfortunately at the
moment and their rights were
were already sold but for example mi4
simple I asked for the riser of the
hours by Michael Cunningham em I'm the
perhaps you will be a surprise I asked
immediately after reading the book for
for the rights or the Silence of the
Lambs
I asked also for their rights of Human
Stain I feel robbed always they and them
and also their winner and I did it very
soon immediately just I read the book
but all of them were sold so I don't
know now I think you know the testing is
something that would you have to respect
but I was not the one to make that
movies that now I admire very much